so this morning i released a video had the most
views i've ever had is 25 000 views an hour
and take take a while to guess what the topic is
corona virus yeah it's a very hot topic right now
you know about i would say 15 years ago i was
doing talks around the governmental agencies
in washington d.c and also exxon mobil and they
kicked me out they actually said you can't talk
anymore i called them up and said why they said
well because you're recommending 45 eggs a day
and that's very bad for the heart i
said no i didn't say 45 i said 4-5
they said oh okay you can come back so
sometimes you have to clarify things
so uh disclosures no financial ties to
pharmaceutical diagnostic or medical devices
or food industry owner of dr bird.com dr berg
supplements authored the healthy keto plan i
organized a summit called the healthy keto
summit every year and my bias is low carb
so today i want to talk about some unique problems
that happen in the keto uh world i have a large uh
following on social media i have a facebook close
private group of 300 thousand people and i'm it's
called my keto lab i'm able to test different
things to see what works see what problems that
people are running into and uh gain a tremendous
amount of understanding about what people are
running into and what the solutions are so i
want to share today some common problems and
solutions one of the biggest ones being plateau
it's keto stall so i want to talk about that first
so a couple couple things one is that you
have people who say well it's not working
i only lost two pounds the first week i
lost six and now i just lost two pounds
i'm like well you have to understand that is
normal so it takes a little bit of education
at first to set people up but there's there's
different levels of awareness that you have to
understand you have awareness of the
problem awareness of the cause of the
problem awareness of the solution
and also of the correct solution so
like i would take like men for example they might
have this huge belly but they're not very aware
that that is a fatty liver they're they're
just like oh yeah it's fine i can deal with it
so i wouldn't necessarily go right
into teaching them about what to eat
because that's too high level so i really address
people where they're at and then build them up
and one of the things i found is that you have
to teach them the basics of certain things
uh especially like one guy came in he goes um
yeah your program's not working i tried it for two
weeks and it didn't work well it did work but then
it stopped working well what did you do well i
stopped stop the diet i said did you think it was
going to keep working if you stop so you really
have to educate people from the very beginning and
so there's a really important very vital principle
that i talk about and that is about it's not lose
weight to get healthy it's get healthy to lose the
weight and this is so basic because looking at
diabetes as a disease doesn't work as this being
this is like this cause of cause situation
it's the effect of course of high insulin
if someone does not understand this concept
they're very susceptible to doing the wrong
solution very unhealthy programs diet
appetite suppressants low quality
products they try to get they try to actually
diet to lose weight how many of you agree that
dieting actually destroys your metabolism you
take someone who's menopause and you ask them
how many diets have you been on it's probably
been 10 or 12 and every time they do it
of course they're doing it wrong it slows down
the metabolism so just because someone's losing
weight doesn't mean they're getting healthy
it really depends on how they're losing weight
so there's some products that people think
are healthy you have you know of course the
slim fast hidden sugars if you take a look at the
ingredients high levels of soy protein isolates
which are exposed to hexane which in pubmed is a
neurotoxin and there's no fda has no sealing of
how much hexane is in there had a lot of clients
come in that have done like programs like ideal
protein that really high in soy protein isolates
and end up with liver and gallbladder issues so
and they're hidden sugars as well so is a
really important question that i always always
ask people to figure things out and i think
it's just it's not emphasized and that is okay
when did this problem start and what happened
just before that and you can get so much data
i had one lady came in with a heart attack
a heart attack symptoms she's been to the
hospital spent forty thousand dollars worth
of testing and nothing showed up and then we
find out i said when did you start well two
weeks ago what day tuesday what did you eat
she was oh a big banana split i said okay laid
it on my table started doing some work on her
and it was basically just a congested gallbladder
backed up in the liver causing heart pain all
the all the heart symptoms went away so
it's really really important to find out
what occurred just before you started having
that problem i asked that question a lot
maltodextrin glycemic index way higher than
glucose and sugar so obesity is a symptom
it's not if you focus on obesity you're going to
basically you're not going to be as successful
it's coming from too much insulin so i have
people focus on other indicators of health i
try to get them off the weight loss at first
because they may not lose weight initially
especially if they have a slow metabolism
so i always ask them how is your energy is
your hunger going away that's a good indication
that the insulin is coming back in a good range
carb cravings if you still have carb cravings
there's still there's a problem with your blood
sugars is your belly shrinking um there are people
women that are actually menopausal that have a lot
of atrophy and it looks just like fat identical
because what happens after menopause is sometimes
you have a spike in cortisol cortisol tends to
turn muscle protein into glucose and then it
raises insulin so you have this loss of muscle
looks like cellulite and fat and they're really
adamantly want to lose weight but this takes
some time to heal this process so in the process
they're building up their proteins you know it
takes months and months maybe even a year or two
to build up this protein back there where actually
they're per volume the muscle is heavier than the
fat so everything is shrinking they're not losing
weight you just have to teach them that this is
normal they have to know that so they're not
setting themselves up for a loss so the most
important thing that a person could do to increase
their health is to use their own fat as fuel
so there's several advantages of doing this number
one now you start running on ketones and there's a
lot of advantage it's a superior fuel more energy
output appetite suppressant more efficient better
lipid profiles tumors can't consume ketones
reduce oxidative stress and more o2 less co2
and then you have the benefits of reduction
of insulin which is the common denominator
of so many health problems i mean inflammatory
conditions heart of course diabetes the fatty
liver high cholesterol aneurysms stroke
dementia other than that it doesn't have
any effects but it's actually pretty connected
to everything so you get to do these two things
there's a you know about the glycemic
index there's actually an insulin index
too how many of you have not familiar with the
insulin index okay those are that's a scale
that um it's all the non-carbohydrate triggers
or the non-carbohydrate influences on insulin
and of course fat is the lowest effect
on insulin but lean low low-fat protein
like whey protein is very high on the
scale of the insulin index and this is why
the keto works really good because you have higher
fat higher fat if you have a whole egg for example
versus the egg whites you have a much less insulin
spike and this is important just understanding um
what we're trying to do we're trying to create as
much health benefit by the reduction of insulin
and so you have the lowering of carb we don't want
to be afraid of fat and we need to understand that
scale but we also want to look at other ways of
decreasing insulin and one of the biggest ways is
fasting intermittent fasting um fasting
is not low carb it's no carb and uh
what happens there's a little hormone called
the gip hormone in the small intestine that gets
activated every time you eat no matter what you
eat so if you don't understand that you may not
put emphasis on fasting and realize that
that's really important especially in the
helping people with really resistant weight
problems and that's very beneficial so the
combination of both of these are vitally important
insulin is a dominating hormone in the presence of
too much insulin a lot of the other hormones
are suppressed especially growth hormone
insulin-like growth factor
and then you get uh when you consult
people you get this thing where um
uh you find out they're on sorta keto uh how many
of you ever had clients that are in sort of keto
yeah i'm not losing weight well what are you
doing well on sort of keto well keto is like
you can't be in sorta keto i mean it just
doesn't work it's like a switch there's
gonna be a point where you're you're not gonna
get into ketosis there's a certain amount of
carbohydrates that you need to go below and if
your metabolism is low it has to be even lower
so i know this might be hard to believe
but some of your your patients or clients
do cheat occasionally and they
don't tell you that they cheat
they keep it a little secret how many have
ever had that happen once once before so
what happens is they keep a little secret and
they do it again and again you're coaching
them and you go they're not getting results what's
interesting about this is they tend to be a bit um
critical to kind of justify it and so i have
learned in practice i have an advantage of being
a practice for 29 years i work with so many people
that um i see this common scenario that happens
if a client comes in that's not
progressing and they're critical
like they'll say well you know i really
don't like the color of your walls and
and your secretary is just so rude and i'm not
losing weight and i go thank you very much i have
a question is there anything that you're eating
that you shouldn't be eating i look them right
in the eye and they'll look they'll do this
like no they look down you know right there
they're not telling the truth so i don't make them
feel guilty says well what do you think about when
they ask you that question they go well i did have
a little ice cream but it was organic you know
i said okay good anything else uh potato chips
but i didn't have that many i got okay how many
do you have well i did have a bag okay and i
just keep going anything else and you will be
shocked to find out these guys are consuming
massive amounts of junk food on the side
found out this one lady she's doing literally i
think a whole bag of oreo cookies every single day
so it's very important if you're coaching someone
to know that because if you don't know that you're
going to be uh trying something else and they're
going to eventually leave and you're going to
be chop living so it's i spend a lot of time just
keeping that communication line open so there's no
secrets i don't care if they cheat just
tell me i want that communication line open
so for those people that have a very slow
metabolism and i know you have some clients
that no matter what you do they just can't nothing
works okay let's put you in a 500 calorie diet
still doesn't work have you exercised more it
doesn't work strict keto it doesn't work you
ever have a client like that yeah they're usually
menopausal they usually have the thyroid removed
the gallbladder removed they're pre-diabetic
and they have a history of many different diets
and now they end up in your office and you're
like okay what do i got to do with this
so what i will do is i'll i'll do all the things
i told you then i'll start to go down the list and
start to really beef up no pun intended the
intermittent fasting so i will decrease the
frequency of eating and i'll have them
fast longer there's a really important
rule that i tell my clients and also even the
videos right now is that don't eat if you're not
hungry do not eat if you're not hungry because
then you're going to be hungry when you eat
because it stimulates insulin so then the blood
sugar comes down so it's so simple and so these
individuals what happens is they're they're going
a long period of time and i told them they have
two meals a day i said are you hungry now i
just eat them because you told me i said okay
let's go to one meal a day all right and i'll do
that are they progressing sometimes they're not
they're not really um seeing the um the changes
that they really need and they have maybe a huge
belly and you just have to come up with something
that's a little more powerful so i will um i'll
do this kind of a stair step method the first
thing is i'll take their uh their um breakfast
and i'll say listen if you're in the morning
if you're not hungry just don't skip it and
start pushing it forward to lunch and so pretty
pretty much there the lunch the breakfast is gone
and so they have lunch and dinner and then what
i'll do is i'll take the lunch and the dinner and
i'll start squeezing them together and until
the point where it's like a four-hour window
most people do very very well with this and i do
have quite a few people doing this on my lab with
tremendous amounts of success some people need
to do one meal a day the key is making sure they
have enough nutrients in that meal you know to
prevent things like hair loss which i will cover
now some some people need to go even a little
bit longer not everyone but i have put people
that fast to the point where they're eating once
every other day now as long as your energy is good
they're taking the nutrients and you'll see that
they'll finally start to change and i have had
a handful of people who were consuming one meal
every other day make sure they do the sea salts
and electrolytes and they finally after all this
time start losing weight so their metabolism is
so efficient that this is what they need and it's
not that they're starving when they're not eating
they're just they're basically eating their own
fat when they're not eating and that's the concept
that you have to get across is that you are eating
when you're not eating you're just eating your fat
so sleeping interesting had a lady who um she
lifted three and a half million pounds at the gym
over course of a year and lost one single pound
and she came in very depressed and i found out
she was not sleeping she was actually on the
right she was eating pretty good but she was
she wasn't sleeping so um i i actually worked with
with sleeping i actually told her to stop watching
the news right before bed that was the big problem
um i told her to start taking calcium magnesium
i did some work on her and she started sleeping
like a baby and that was the only time that things
started to kick in she lost a lot of weight great
before and after i mean don't underwrite sleep
like my wife and i went on a trip uh recently
because we were like completely pale and white in
january so we went to the bahamas to this little
remote little island where they have like no
internet no reception and it got dark around 6:30.
there was nothing to do so we went to bed at 7 00
and i said well let's just go to bed we go to
bed i s we think we slept for 13 or 14 hours
i've never felt that better in my life it
was amazing so i mean i've been running on
maybe six hours if that just getting
more sleep can create huge changes
in your in your blood sugars in your
body so i need to do more of that
okay stress yes that can affect you i think out
of all the stress people have a lot of the stress
comes from other people how many realize that
people can stress people out certain personality
types you got the slow drivers that just really
jack up my adrenals they're just driving and then
you have the antagonistic people but really the
the worst case is the is the passive aggressive
the underminers they're the person they told
you they stood up for you but they actually ruin
your reputation they'll say comments like well
you've done quite well for your educational level
what had this attorney come in to see me
he said i said hey how did you find out
about me he says well out of all the
quacks you seem to be the less weird
it was kind of a hint of a compliment but it's
really kind of just taking my wind out so as
a as a practitioner you're always going to get
a percentage of those people that come in that
are just you don't feel good when they're around
them i screen those out right now i screen those
guys out and they constantly are nullifying
your results if they get results there will
be someone else that worked on them wasn't
you or they'll say comments like hey that's
a nice sweater was that on sale like oh you
got a haircut was that cheap cuts and like
so it's just something about them you don't really
like but i do have a way of i finally figured out
a way of getting back at these people revenge
you want to know how i do it you can do but how
many of you have clients like this yeah this
is what you do it's it's a great great thing
you when they start doing that all you do is you
just look them right in the on the face look them
really close and just say what
what's that has that been growing
has that been growing you should probably get
that checked out yeah get your liver checked out
because that's what they're doing
to you they're introverting you
you just flip it they'll be in the bathroom
for hours looking at that little back there
and like oh my gosh is that the coronavirus
and then just get them out of your space and
but with this attorney that came in uh what
i did is i said um i knew i did not want to
take him on so i said i tell you what this
is what i want to do go up to the front
and i have a bottle of calcium it's four dollars
i want you to buy that go ahead and try that if
it doesn't work i can't help you never saw him
again so nice way of getting rid of those guys
but stress is a really really key thing to oh my
gosh exercise either over exercising over training
or not exercising at all so regular consistent
exercise um creates some really nice effects with
a lot of things autophagy the
cleaning up of old damaged tissue
protects your immune system keeps your body full
of oxygen but i had one lady who came in she was
uh exercising i'm not kidding six hours a day
and no weight loss six hours a day at the gym
so she was over training so i had her which took a
long time to do this but i got her to exercise um
like for an hour twice a week and she started
to lose the weight and it was really a weird
brain strain because she didn't realize that
overture i mean the benefit of exercise occurs
when you're sleeping the 48 hours later not during
the exercise exercise is a stress the benefits are
delayed she didn't understand that um okay
bloating so you you i do recommend vegetables
for most people but if they start bloating i take
them off of it because they might have sibo small
intestinal bacterial overgrowth they might not
deal with them and so there's been a handful of
people not the majority that would just can't do
well on vegetables so i will adjust what i do but
i do i'll tell you why i recommend more vegetables
in a bit but if they're bloating that can cut down
on the weight loss because they're they're fluid
retained they're just holding the stress in the
gut and that's happened a handful of times so you
want to you know just kind of look at that as well
okay next thing is the transitional phase
when you're getting into ketosis there's
a thing called keto fatigue has anyone
ever experienced that so i had a chance
to just work with a lot of people and find
out this is mostly potassium deficiency
and when you do keto you're no longer running
in carbs so you're going to dump a lot of fluid
because carbs retain fluid with that fluid becomes
electrolytes not just potassium but sodium now our
bodies tend to retain sodium more than potassium
we don't have um any mechanism to retain potassium
hardly at all so there's this false information
being spread that spread out there that potassium
is dangerous on our body if you have well
of course if you have staged kidney disease
yes but if you have healthy kidneys it's not
dangerous in fact potassium is protective of
the kidney if you want date on that i have amazing
research on that you can you can ask me later but
but the thing about potassium is out of
all the nutrients we need potassium in
large amounts 4,700 milligrams a day if you take
a look at what you have to eat to consume that
you're going to find out the majority of
people are just not consuming enough potassium
so um potassium is involved with a lot of things
fluid exchange energy it buffers uric acid
it's really an effective thing for blood
pressure wow it just brings blood pressure
down there's a lot of data on this also heart
rhythm rhythm um really helps with arrhythmias
because it's involved in the
pacemaker nerve and energy muscle
making hcl but the main purpose of
potassium is involved in the sodium
potassium pump in the cells so you have
these little pumps on the cell surface that
you have a billion of them let
me just go right to that first
yeah this is what they look like they have one
purpose to keep the potassium inside the cell
and the sodium outside the cell to keep this
electrical gradient to keep these two minerals
separate that forms through the help of the
insulated wall of that cell it helps to form
develop a battery the body allocates
30 of all of its energy to these pumps
and what the what what this energy this
electrical energy does is it it activates
the nerve and the muscle tissue so if you're
deficient and this pump doesn't have enough
raw material you're going to get weakness
and uh in the muscle and things like that and
so this is one wikipedia so you know it's true
they said it's the causes of hypokalemia low
potassium is uh look at the cause one of the
causes is going a ketogenic diet i don't know if
i believe that but i do know that you'd lose fluid
um with this and so that could be the reason why
also one of the big symptoms of hypokalemia the
first one is feeling tired so if you if you're
into exercise and you're doing endurance exercise
if you take a little more potassium you're going
to find you can go a lot longer too because your
your cellular pumps have are are recharged so
to prevent that i i recommend foods that are high
in um potassium on the ketogenic diet i don't want
to get too much into this but the potassium and
the the insulated phospholipid layer on the cell
acts as a capacitor which basically stores
electrical charge your cells are batteries and
if you divide the amount of voltage which
is uh 150 microvolts inside the cell by
the thickness of the wall which is very small
it can yield electrical fields in excess
of 200 kilovolts that's 200,000 volts
so certainly enough to break down any
most insulators so if you compare that
to anything like underground cables
it smokes anything else so your cells are just
amazing how it can generate this incredible
amount of voltage and activate muscles and if you
make sure that you give it the right nutrients
beet tops have the most potassium per cup
1300 so i mean i don't consume beet tops so
it's uh spinach the problem with spinach that
i have on the keto is it's high in oxalates
if you're prone to kidney stones i have them avoid
spinach brussels sprouts 600 something cabbage 300
tomatoes 400 swiss chard so you can see avocados
830 milligrams asparagus 400 so typically speaking
you're going to get a little more potassium with
greens um but you can also get them from lamb you
can get potassium from lamb 2 268 for 3 ounces
can of tuna is 280 round steak 3 ounces of 300
so you really just have to you should probably uh
yourself or with a client just start calculating
how much potassium is a person really eating and
you may find that it's not even close so you may
want to substitute with calcium citrate or another
type of calcium i'm sorry potassium okay keto flu
is purely a salt deficiency sodium or chloride
no one's really talking about chloride salt is
composed of 40 sodium 60 chlorides chlorides are
really necessary to make the hydrochloric acid
so it's a very important mineral just as sodium
so when you do keto you do need more sea salt
and so that will take care of the flu
flu-like symptoms very quickly and also weak
muscles here's another gem if you
don't know this this is a no-brainer
you're going to have clients come to you that have
peripheral neuropathy and there's a really good
remedy that seems to work the majority of the
time because hyperglycemia depletes vitamin b1
and b1 is involved in making myelin sheath it's
it protects the cells against the complications
of high sugar it's considered a nerve vitamin
when you're low in b1 you get neuritis
you get that excessive thinking thinking and
like nervous anxiety um i like the best source of
b1 being nutritional yeast it's more of a natural
type it rids lactic acid so if you put someone on
metformin one of the side effects it's rare is
lactic acidosis b1 reduces that complication
so if you have someone on metformin if you
have on b12 and b1 that would be very smart
it's involved in four different steps in the
krebs cycle and the mitochondria in the generation
of atp so it's like the spark plug that occurs
when you have fuel and oxygen coming into that
krebs cycle and so if you're not if you've
been on a high carb diet you'll deplete b1
and that's when you start getting
the complications of diabetes and
mainly it's the destruction of the vascular the
capillary function the blood flow to the nerve
and the eye and the nerve and the also the
epithelial cells in the heart and the kidney
as well as in the um the peripheral nerves
not to mention the brain um so ben thought
to me if you've never heard of this it's a fat
style will be one uh it's a no-brainer it it's
quite miraculous and they made it fat soluble
to penetrate the myelin sheath in the brain
and it can be absorbed i think it's seven to nine
times more than waterside will be one but it's a
really um you start like you just get a bottle
of it and have them take uh you know four four
times a day whatever the recommended dosage is and
uh it seems to work for peripheral neuropathies
i will say that some people if it's
really bad it does take months to kick in
alpha lipoic acid also is good as well
but it reduces the oxidative stress
and the complications of diabetes i have a lot
of references if you want it hair loss okay
so you have sometimes people say well keto is very
healthy because you're going to lose all your hair
well that's probably um if you're
doing it incorrectly if you
the the main thing with the hair loss
is you need certain trace minerals
not just for the thyroid um but for the hair
directly so the two trace minerals that seem
to work the majority of time are zinc and selenium
and they both are actually involved in the thyroid
um there's biotin is another really good one as
well if someone has gut issues it could be the
reason why they're not your body makes biotin
so it could be either that you have you don't
have the friendly bacteria to make biotin or
you have gut damage that you're not able to
absorb that biotin so sometimes i'll give people
biotin in higher amounts to kick in the hair
but zinc is a really important thing
so what i do is i make sure that
they do what's called a healthy
version of keto which is high density
nutrient foods especially the trace
minerals and that would be the shellfish
these are high zinc foods tuna eggs pumpkin
seeds lamb fish as well as selenium is another
important one selenium is probably one of the
most important trace mineral antioxidants really
important in the thyroid especially hashimoto's
because you have all this inflammatory reactions
and to counter all that free radical damage
that's happening with hydrogen peroxide and
so selenium is really important and where do you
get it you get it actually in fish and seafood so
this is just a chart to show you the the mercury
some people are concerned about mercury as long as
you have enough selenium it'll counter the mercury
so like the three types of fish that you wouldn't
want to consume would be pilot whale which i know
i i really love that uh mako shark or swordfish
but everything else is is pretty good so you
don't necessarily have to work worry about that
selenium tuna brazil nuts eggs sardines halibut
sunflower seeds spinach and beef shellfish you
can see that different different uh nutrients
contain a lot of different trace minerals uh so a
well rounded meal would be fine shellfish i think
is is great for keto as long as it's a you know
healthy version key additional because i'm
trying to go fast because i can see the times
running out here key foods i do recommend
a small amount of dairy for certain people
but if they start getting acne if they
have problems with fibroids if they have
a prostate problem i'm going to take them
off dairy um but because i'm from wisconsin
um i like high quality dairy and of course i do
the grass-fed uh organic um at halloween we gave
out um these little mini packs and you know these
kids just don't come back anymore i don't know why
i want to thank you for coming and listening and
have a wonderful afternoon thank you very much